[Music]  tonight  the world is full  of life  [Music]  this is my first time in new york city  i want to be happy here i want to make a  life at home  [Music]  are you ready  tonight is about family  the first gringo boy who smiles at you  i never seen you before  you're not puerto rican  is that okay  do you want to start world war three  you know i wake up to everything i know  either getting sold or wrecked or being  taken over by people that i don't like  you keep away from him as long as you're  in my house i'm a grown up now bernardo  i'm gonna think for myself  tony  we need you if we're going to war  who are you  wonderful  if you go with him  no one will ever forgive you  [Music]  life matters  even more than love  [Music]  [Music]  you